Gary is getting older and you know I
feel bad I don't want to make fun of
Gary he even has some new disease I
never heard of what what disease you
know he is weird like remember his
toenails were all [__] up and I didn't
want him in my pool I invited him over
my home and he went in my and it's like
those toenails I said I'm Gonna Catch
whatever the [__] fungus is he's got
on his toenails and he gets these
diseases but now he's got one called
Deputy syndrome
deputin syndrome is that how you say it
the future Tell Robin what's happening
to you okay you see my pinky it's stuck
like that it's in that position oh dear
and it's only going to get worse unless
I get it fixed see so I'm trying to I
couldn't I couldn't bend it if I tried
what happened you woke up one day and
you can't move your pinky I go to the
doctor and basically they say these
things go around your tendons and they
become like Vines and it's it's a
hardening of the hand and um to get it
fixed I have to go to the doctor it's a
two-day process they have to put an
injection in there right and which
apparently is really painful
and then you go back the next day and
they they [__] twist your thing to
get the you know the vines off the
tendon after I get it done I have to
wear a splint on my pinky every night
when I go to sleep for four months
he gets weird diseases yeah it's weird
it says uh knots of tissue form under
the skin they eventually create a thick
cord that can pull the fingers into a
bent position how [__] up is Humanity
wow his finger looks like it belongs to
the Elephant Man now that can put two in
the pink but none in the stink
foreign